[موسيقى]
المعلم عباس
انت رجل
انك راح تخلط علي
الزفت
كل شيء بالحاره
انا اللي جذبني لهذا الفيلم هو حياه
الحاره
قرب الناس من بعض هي زي عيله مكبره
الناس
بدي الملعب على بعض في نوع من الاخوه اممم
بس في نفس الوقت قرب الناس على بعض همم
بيخلق نوع من
الضغط
يعني من وجهه نظري همم امراه تلبسون نوع
من القناع همم عشان يخبوا شخصياتهم همم
الاصليه همم بس هذا قناع نوع من الصراع ما
بين القناع الشخص لابسه في المجتمع همم
والشخص نفسه
[موسيقى]
البحث جزء اساسي من الكتاب الى الافلام
ولغير الافلام امم فها كانت مرحله طولت
معنا اكثر من اكثر من سنتين ثلاثه
اشتغلت مع صديق الي اسمه محمود ابو فرحات
محمود ابن الحاره مثل ما تفضلتي عايش
ببيئه
وكان جزء اساسي بالكتابه وتطوير القصه همم
فاستوحينا من قصص الشارع واستوحينا من
القصص اللي سمعناها ومسكنا الطرف الحبل
نحكي همم ومنها طورنا القصه
وطبعا يعني الفيلم مش اسم ابني على القصص
هاي والواقعيه هاي هاي الفيلم كمان مبني
على الافلام اللي احنا بنحبها الافلام
التجاريه
الجماهيريه فهي نوع من الخلط ما بين همم
البحث اللي عملنا والقصص اللي بنسمعها
بالشارع
والافلام اللي همم
نحب ان اقل ده
لسه المخفي
اكثر من مكشوف
[موسيقى]
بالافلام التجاريه بالعاده نحن بالانجليزي
بقولوا لها
بالافلام الجنرا هي بتركب قالب معين تمام
اذا الواحد بمشي على القالب تماما اذا هو
عمل فيلم تجاري بحث بما معنى انه لعب على
عناصر معينه مثلا في فيلم همم اجرامي
بيكون في دائما شخص همم كويس وشخص شرير
خلينا نحكي مثلا بيكون فيه نوع من البحث
او بيزوس بتكون في همم
العنف جزء منه او بجوز يكون في المخدرات
او وكذا وكذا وكذا
الواحد اذا بده يطول او يبعد عن فكره انه
يعمل فيلم ربحت بده يطول على هذا الشيء
ويبني عليه وهمم بالعكس ممكن يلعب على همم
توقعات المشاهد همم وياخذ الافكار بجوز
يعني همم
[موسيقى]
الكاتب المخرج بجزء من الوصف فيها ابعد
شوي من الفيلم يعني
تروح
جبل نظيف كان كثير ما كان متناسب للقصه
لانه
القصص اللي بنسمعها بالشارع يعني مسموعه
عندهم بالحرارات والروح الحاره موجود
يعني بجوز الفيلم
يطلع على الجهه الصاعده ننجب نضيف بس هذا
لا يعني انه
الجبل جبل النظيف مش مكان جميل وفيه ااا
علاقات وناس بتجنن ولولاهم كان الفيلم ما
عملتش لانه هم جزء من الفيلم لا يتجزا من
صناع الفيلم
[موسيقى]
اهل جبل شاف الفيلم اه اجوا معنا على
العرض الاول طبعا بالاردن كانت تجربه
بتجنن فمن همم
حاسه
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لي انا كنت همم سعيد جدا اكون همم
جزء من
هذا الفيلم اني اشتغل معهم وانه هم يحسوا
انه هذا فيلمهم ويرفعوا راسهم فيه
الجيش في الحاره هاي
[موسيقى]